you know that mode in the new doom that  the developers couldn't even beat ultra  nightmare mode combines dooms hardest  difficulty with perma death and it looks  like someone has already beaten it not  to mention youtuber zero master  completed it in less than five hours  they know that it's not always the most  entertaining playthrough to watch but it  gets the job done you can watch the full  video on zero masters YouTube channel  zero master says their next challenge is  to complete doom two's nightmare mode in  under 23 minutes which requires them to  race through the entire game at its  hardest difficulty their current record  comes in at 23 minutes and six seconds  what you can also watch on zero masters  channel doom launched last week for  PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC if you  want to know more about the gory shooter  check out our review and for more gaming  news you're already in the right place  [Music]